Let's go next to our caller from the three
one five area code.
Who's calling today from three one five.
Hi David.
This is Janice.
I see a lot of stats about, uh, climate change
and automation.
And I see that they, uh, the worst effects
of them happen to coincide around the same
decades around the 2040s and 2050s.
And I'm wondering, do you think that a liberal
democracy or Western civilization or whatever
you call it, uh, how confident are you that
these things are gonna Survive?
Uh, things like automation and climate change?
Well, I think there's a bigger question you're
asking in general, which is it can feel for
us right now in the middle of it, like liberal
democracy and the sort of type of geopolitical
status quo that we have is just the way things
are going to be indefinitely.
And then as soon as you just zoom out a little
bit, you see the impermanence of just about
everything that has existed.
And so my doubts about being able to say x
or y is going to survive beyond a particular
point is that in general we just have a huge
bias towards believing that the way things
are now are the way things are going to remain.
It's very hard for us to imagine how things
could be drastically different.
But you know, like Rome fell eventually.
And if history has taught us anything to the
extent that we know history, it's that even
things that seem permanent are not.
So as far as climate change specifically,
there are a number of different theories and
ideas about how quickly things are going to
happen, automation, et Cetera.
The truth is we're pretty damn bad as a species
at predicting what is going to be going on
beyond like five years at least.
Societaly now scientific predictions are different.
Things move at a glacial pace, no pun intended.
Um, but even still, I don't, I think that
what we're identifying now are trends and
the specificity that is sometimes attributed
is maybe a little overzealous in terms of
how good we are at predicting things because
there will be inflection points that continue
to kind of like modify their trajectory.
But I think with all of these questions there
are real, it's a serious open question as
to whether a humanity will survive as we know
it, beyond, you know, relatively modest periods
of time.
Well, I'm not worried so much about the survival
of the human race, just the, uh, I guess all
the progress we've made in the past say 200
years.
Yeah, they're there.
It's completely reasonable to think that there
could be a significant backslide.
There's a lot of speculative fiction that
has explored ways in which it would happen,
where we would effectively, as you're saying,
go back to the way things were 150 or 200
years ago.
And I mean, I just don't know the, you know,
the, the reason that these questions are hard
for me is like, I can just speculate, but
I just know that we're terrible at this stuff
at predicting the stuff.
Like, I just don't know.
I don't think we know.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.